♪ ♪
GOOD EVENING AMERICA.
AMERICA WELCOME TO CROSS KRKT I
BEGIN WITH A FOX NEWS ALERT
THAT'S TOP BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
OFFICIALS ARE SITTING DOWN WITH
THE TALIBAN.
THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF THE CI
SARKS AMONG U.S. REPRESENTATIVES
WHO MET WITH TALIBAN LEADERS IN
DOHA TODAY IT IS FIRST SUCH
MEETING SINCE THE U.S. KILLED
THE LEADER OF AL QAEDA IN KABUL
IN LATE JULY.
HERE TO HELP US MAKE SENSE OF
ALL OF THIS, A FORMER DEPUTY
COMMANDING GENERAL IN
AFGHANISTAN AND AUTHOR OF
CHASING THE LION RETIRE ARMY
GENERAL ANTHONY TATA SIR THANK
YOU SO MUCH.
I GUESS THE BEST QUESTION IS,
WHY ARE WE STILL TALKING WITH
THE TALIBAN?
WE KNOW THEY ARE CONTINUING TO
HARBOR TERRORISTS.
WE KNOW CZAR HERI AND MASTERMIND
BEHIND A LOT OF THINGS HE WASN'T
AS CHARISMATIC BUT HE WAS BRAINS
BEHIND ALL OF THEIR OPERATIONS.
>> WELL YOU'RE EXACTLY RIGHT
LAWRENCE, DISAWMED HAD ALAN MORE
OF THE FASHION AL QAEDA
OPERATION BUT AT THE END OF THE
DAY IT'S A GOOD THING THAT HE'S
DEAD AND GONE.
IT WAS GOOD THAT WE DID THAT.
THE UNITED STATES CONTINUING TO
NEGOTIATE WITH THE TALIBAN MAKES
LITTLE SENTENCE MY VIEW THE DOHA
AGREEMENT SIGNED COUPLE OF WEEKS
AGO DURING TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
THAT BEGAN THE PHASEOUT OF
FOREIGN TROOPS FROM AFGHANISTAN
WAS A GOOD AGREEMENT.
AND IT WAS POORLY EXECUTED BY
THIS, YOU KNOW, LAST YEAR ABOUT
A YEAR AGO.
BY THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
ABOUT WHAT WE HAVE NOW IS NO
REAL AGREEMENT IN PLACE BECAUSE
THEY'RE NOT ABIDING BY THAT
AGREEMENT AS YOU SAID HARBORING
TERRORISTS AND SO THE FOUR
POINTS OF THAT AGREEMENT WORK TO
REDUCE VIOLENCE WITHDRAW FOREIGN
TROOPS AND BEGAN INSTRAW AFGHAN
NEGOTIATION AND THERE'S REALLY
NO U.S. VITAL INTEREST ANYMORE
IN AFGHANISTAN.
AND RIGHT NOW THEY'VE GOT ISIS-K
FIGHTING THE TALIBAN AND YOU
KNOW I WOULD SAY LET THAT PLAY
OUT A LITTLE BIT.
IT IS BAD FOR THE AFGHAN PEOPLE.
BUT ARE THERE, BUT RIGHT NOW
IT'S NOT WORTH OUR TIME AND
EFFORT TO ENGAGE IN AFGHANISTAN
FOR MY POINT OF VIEW.
>> GENERAL WHAT SHOULD BE DOING
RIGHT NOW THAT WE KNOW THAT
THEY'RE STILL TRYING TO HARM
AMERICANS.
SO WHAT SHOULD THE RESPONSE FROM
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION?
>> WELL I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT WE, THEY ONLY REALLY
OPPORTUNITY HERE IS THE
INTELLIGENCE GATHERING IF THE
TALIBAN IS BEGINNING TO WORRY
ABOUT ISIS K. TO EXTEND THAT RKS
IA AND OTHER AGENCIES GATHER
INTELLIGENCE THAT CAN HELP US
FIND AND RESCUE ANY AMERICANS
THAT ARE STILL THERE.
OF COURSE, THAT'S A VITAL
INTEREST THAT WE SHOULD PURSUE.
BUT YOU KNOW, THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION SET ASIDE THREE
AND A HALF BILLION DOLLARS FOR
THE TALIBAN, AND I WOULD SAY
LET'S THAT I CAN THREE AND A
HALF BILLION AND GIVE IT TO
VETERANS WHO FOUGHT IN
AFGHANISTAN.
U.S. ARMY NAVY AIR FORCE MARINE
CORPS. VETERANS THAT FOUGHT
OPPOSED TO GIVING MONEY TO
TALIBAN.
BUT INTELLIGENCE SHARING I
THINK, LAWRENCE, IS A GOOD
THING.
GETTING THAT INFORMATION YOU SEE
PART OF THAT DELEGATION WAS FROM
THE CIA.
SO, YOU KNOW, AS LONG AS THAT'S
WHAT THEY'RE DOING A LOW LEVEL
KIND OF CONVERSATION ABOUT
GATHERING INTELLIGENCE AND
GETTING U.S. CITIZENS OUT OF
THERE, I THINK THAT THAT IS OUR
ONLY INTEREST THERE.
>> GENERAL THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
ROLLING WITH US WITH THE